>>> HAPPY THURSDAY.
WE ARE BACK, BABY.
LISTEN, IFORTUNEORENTED BY FAN .
DIVING INTO THE DATA EVERY WEEK
IS ERIN DOLAN.
AND GREG IVORY.
WE CALL HIM G MONEY.
LET'S GET IT.
TONIGHT IS GAME TWO OF THE SUNS
AND BUCKS IN THE NBA FINALS.
G MONEY HAS BEEN GIVING AWAY
JERSEYS ALL PLAYOFFS.
NOW THAT IT'S THE FINALS, WE
WILL CRANK IT UP A KNOCK.
TELL THE CHAT.
>> I SAW HOW MUCH YOU ALL LIKED
THE JERSEYS.
WE PUT OUR HEADS TOGETHER TO
FIGURE OUT SOMETHING FANCY FOR
THE FINALS.
WE COOKED UP SOMETHING SPECIAL.
REAL SPECIAL FOR Y'ALL.
WE'RE GIVING AWAY UP TO $5,000
IN SNEAKERS MONEY DURING THE
FINALS.
TODAY WE'RE GOING TO GIVE OUT
SIX $250 SNEAKER GIFT CARDS TO
PUT TOWARD WHATEVER KICKS YOU
GUYS WANT.
I'M GIVING OUT THREE PAIRS RIGHT
HERE ON THE SHOW.
STAY TUNED.
MAKE SURE YOU GUYS STAY TAPPED
IN.
WE'RE GIVING OUT ANOTHER PAIR ON
VR SOCIAL, ONE ON THE APP AND WE
ARE GOING TO GIVE OUT ANOTHER
PAIR ON KICKS.
I'M FEELING JENNEROUS.
I'M GOING TO GIVE OUT THE FIRST
PAIR RIGHT NOW.
GET IN THE COMMENTS AND TELL ME
WHAT KICKS WOULD YOU BUY RIGHT
NOW IF YOU HAD $250 TO GO GET
KICKS, WHAT KICKS WOULD YOU BUY?
WHILE YOU DO THAT, ERIN, WHAT
KICKS WOULD YOU BUY?
>> I WOULD BUY JORDANS.
EVEN SLCELEBRITIES ARE BUYING
THEM.
IT'S IN STYLE.
>> YOU ARE GOING TO BUY Js
BECAUSE FAMOUS PEOPLE ARE
WEARING --
>> THEY'RE ICONIC.
THEY ARE ICONIC.
BUT I'M SO SHORT.
I FELT THEY WOULD LOOK HUGE ON
ME.
I'M SEEING MORE FEMALES WEAR
THEM, I CAN ROCK THEM.
>> OKAY.
>> HOW MANY PAIRS DO YOU OWN?
>> ZERO CURRENTLY.
>> ZERO?
>> WE GOTTA GIVE YOU SOME OF THE
GIFT CARDS.
>> GIVE ME THE $250.
>> WE GOTTA GIVE YOU SIX OF THEM
IMMEDIATELY.
>> THEY ARE SO EXPENSIVE.
>> TRUE.
THEY ARE WORTH IT BECAUSE
THEY'RE CLASSICS.
I SAW THE PUMA ALL PROs, THE
CLYDE FRAZIER PUMA ALL PROS.
I LOVE THE WHITE AND BLUE, THAT
COLOR.
BECAUSE IT'S THE SUMMERTIME, I
THINK -- I'M GOING TO TRY TO
SQUEEZE TWO PAIRS OF KICKS IN A
$250 GIFT CARD.
I LOVE THE JUICY FRUIT.
IT'S THE SUMMER.
I NEED SNEAKERS THAT POP.
I'M A FUN GUY.
YOU KNOW WHAT I MEAN?
WHAT SNEAKERS WOULD YOU GET?
IF YOU GIFTED ONE OF THOSE CARDS
FOR YOURSELF.
>> IF I HAD $250 RIGHT NOW, HAVE
BEEN -- I HAVE BEEN EXPANDING
THE SHOE GAME.
JUST A LITTLE BIT.
JUST PICKED UP SOME THE OTHER
DAY.
>> MONEY BAGS.
>> IF I WAS GOING TO GO GET
SHOES RIGHT NOW, I WOULD GO GRAB
THOSE EASY SLIDES.
I NEED SOME COMFORTABLE SHOES TO
WALK AROUND THE HOUSE.
>> WAIT.
ARE YOU TALKING ABOUT THE FOAM
RUNNERS THAT LOOK LIKE A
HONEYCOMB OR THE BASIC SLIDES?
>> NO, NO, NO.
THE BASIC SLIDES.
THE BASIC.
NOT THE HONEYCOMB ONE.
>> YOU JUST WEAR THEM IN YOUR
HOUSE.
>> NO, NO, I MIGHT WEAR THEM TO
A POOL PARTY IF I'M FEELING IT.
>> YOU ARE FROM CALIFORNIA.
>> MAINLY IN THE HOUSE.
>> DO YOU WEAR SLIDES WITH
SOCKS?
>> THAT'S A GREAT QUESTION.
THAT'S A GREAT QUESTION.
>> YOU ARE FROM CALIFORNIA.
GUYS DO IT DIFFERENTLY ON THE
WEST COAST.
>> RECENTLY, I MEAN, IT DEPENDS
ON WHERE I'M GOING.
IT DEPENDS ON THE VIBE, WHERE
I'M GOING.
IF I'M GOING TO THE BARBER SHOP,
I'M GOING TO PUT ON SOCKS.
I'M GOING TO COVER UP MY FEET.
COVER UP MY MONEY MAKERS.
>> YOU ARE IN VEGAS RIGHT NOW.
YOU ARE GOING TO A FIGHT.
>> IF I'M IN VEGAS, NO SOCKS.
GOTTA LET IT BE FREE.
LET THE FEET DO THEIR THING.
>> HERE WE GO.
LET ME GIVE OUT THE $250 I THINK
THE COMMENTS -- I THINK THEY ARE
THERE.
LET ME GET IN HERE AND SEE, WHO
IS DESERVING OF THIS $250?
I GOT -- I GOT 88 GOAT SAYS AIR
JORDAN, ROCKING WITH THE THAT.
I GOT THE -- THE COMMENTS ARE
MOVING.
THEY ARE MOVING.
THEY ARE JUNING TODAY.
I GOT CALSENIOR7 SAYS THE
JORDANS.
THE NEXT ONE I'M GOING TO GIVE
HIM THE MONEY.
I'M JUST GOING TO GIVE HIM THE
MONEY.
I'M GOING TO GIVE IT TO -- I GOT
LI
LIAMO'CONNELL.
HE SAID, ANY JORDAN.
I HAVE NO SHOE GAME.
SHOULD WE GIVE IT TO HIM?
>> YOU SHOULD HAVE --
>> HE GONE NAING TO KNOW WHERE T
THE MONEY.
>> THE TATUMS ARE DOPE.
ZION HAS THE ONES THAT ARE DOPE.
YOU HAVE TO BE MORE SPECIFIC.
>> MORE SPECIFIC.
WE WILL GET MORE SPECIFIC.
SG
I GOT MOPAR702 BLACK CEMENT
JORDAN 3.
SHOUTOUT TO MOPAR702, YOU ARE
WALKING AWAY WITH $250.
WE HAVE MORE SHOES TO GIVE AWAY
DURING THE SHOW.
LOTS OF BASKETBALL TO DISCUSS.
LET'S GET INTO IT.
GAME ONE, THE POINT GOD CHRIS
PAUL WAS MATCHUP HUNTING AND
TARGETING.
HE ATE THEIR FOOD.
HE COOKED THEM FOR 32 POINTS.
WE ASKED YOU ON SOCIAL AND IN
THE APP, HOW MANY POINTS WILL
CP3 SCORE TONIGHT?
>> EVERYBODY IN THE COMMENTS,
GET BACK INTO THE COMMENTS.
THAT MEANS TYPE UP SOMETHING.
GET IN THE COMMENTS AND TELL ME
HOW MANY POINTS CHRIS PAUL IS
PUTTING UP TONIGHT AT THE END OF
THE GAME WE WILL DM ONE PERSON
WHO GETS THE CLOSEST AND HOOK
YOU UP WITH $250 IN SNEAKER
MONEY.
ERIN, CP3 SITTING AT 21 1/2
POINTS.
HOW DO YOU FEEL ABOUT THAT
NUMBER?
>> HE SCORES 32 IN GAME ONE.
HE IS AVERAGING 19 PER GAME THIS
POSTSEASON.
QUICKLY, WANTED TO ADD HE LEADS
THE SUNS IN ASSISTS AND STEALS.
BEFORE THIS, I DO LIKE THE OVER.
I DOUBTED HIM LAST GAME.
ALTHOUGH HE MAY NOT BE ABLE TO
PUT UP 32 POINTS AGAIN, BECAUSE
THE BUCKS ARE GOING TO ADJUST
THEIR DEFENSE FOR GAME TWO, I
THINK HE CAN HIT THE OVER
21 1/2.
>> EVEN WITH PARTIALLY TORN
LIGAMENTS IN HIS RIGHT HAND,
CHRIS PAUL WAS IN HIS BAG
KNOCKING DOWN MIDRANGE AFTER
MIDRANGE JUMPER.
IT LOOKED LIKE AN OPEN RUN AT
THE YMCA.
LIKE ERIN SAID, MILWAUKEE WILL
MAKE ADJUSTMENTS.
THE GUARDS HAVE TO FIGHT OVER
THEIR SCREENS.
THE BIGS HAVE TO ADJUST.
LOPEZ WILL HAVE TO CROSS THESE
FINGERS, THESE FINGERS, THESE
FINGERS, TOES AND HOPE THAT
CHRIS MALL WILL BE A PLAYMAKER
VERSUS A SCORER TONIGHT.
I'M GOING TO TAKE THE UNDER AT
25 1/2 POINTS.
ALSO LOCK IN A CHRIS PAUL DOUBLE
DOUBLE.
I FEEL GOOD ABOUT THAT.
G MONEY WHAT PREDICTIONS ARE YOU
SEEING IN THE COMMENTS ABOUT
CHRIS PAUL'S PERFORMANCE IN GAME
TWO?
>> I'M SEEING ALL TYPES OF
PREDICTIONS IN THE COMMENTS.
MY GUY LIAM O'CONNELL, THE GUY
THAT I DID NOT GIVE THE $250 TO,
I'M GIVING HIM A HOODIE THIS
TIME.
I'M GIVING HIM A HOODIE BECAUSE
HIS COMMENT WENT AWAY, BUT I
FEEL LIKE I OWE HIM.
>> HOW MANY POINTS DID HE SAY?
>> HIS COMMENT WENT AWAY.
IT WENT AWAY.
>> OKAY.
>> WE WILL FIND IT.
COMMENTS ARE JUMPING.
I DON'T KNOW IF YOU ARE PAYING
ATTENTION, BUT THEY ARE JUMPING.
KAOENE.
THEY SAID, 29 POINTS, 6
REBOUNDS, 11 ASSISTS.
LOVE THE DETAILS.
LOVE THE DETAILS THERE.
I'M GOING TO -- YOU ARE WALKING
AWAY WITH A HOODIE.
JDDONICH SAID 22.
SQUEAKING BY THE HOOK.
22, SHOUTOUT, YOU ARE WALKING
AWAY WITH A HOODIE.
LIAM SAID HE IS TAKING THE OVER.
MUCH LOVE TO YOU, LIAM.
ONE MORE.
I GOT ONE MORE.
I GOT MONEYMAN13, HE WILL DROP
THE MOST -- THE MODEST 21 AND 10
ASSISTS.
TAKE THE UNDER.
HE SAYS THIS IS BOOKER'S GAME.
CHRIS PAUL WILL DROP 21 AND HE
WILL HAVE 10 ASSISTS.
SHOUTOUT TO YOU.
STAY HERE.
STAY HERE BECAUSE WE HAVE MORE.
WE HAVE MORE SNEAKER MONEY TO
GIVE AWAY.
YOU GUYS DROPPING THE COMMENTS,
LET US KNOW HOW MANY POINTS IS
CP3 PUTTING UP?
A PAIR OF KICKS OFF THE GAME TO
ONE WINNER WHO WAS THE CLOSEST.
WE ALSO GOT TWO MORE TO GIVE
AWAY RIGHT HERE IN THIS SHOW.
LET'S KEEP IT GOING.
>> QUICK BEFORE WE MOVE ON,
WHERE DO YOU STAND ON CP3?
OVER OR THE UNDER AT 21 1/2.
>> I'M WORRIED ABOUT GIVING AWAY
THE SHOES AND THE HOODIES.
I FORGOT TO GIVE MY TAKE.
I'M ROCKING WITH THE OVER.
THE OVER HERE.
MY GUY CP3 IS ON A MISSION.
HE IS OPEN A MISSION.
I THINK HE IS GOING TO ELEVATE
HIS SCORING BECAUSE HE KNOWS IF
HIS -- IF HE HAS IMPACT ON
SCORING AS WELL AS DISHING THE
BALL AROUND, TO HIS PLAYMAKERS,
IT'S GOING TO MAKE I HAD TEAM
THAT MUCH BETTER.
I'M ROCKING WITH THE OVER AND
BETTING ON CP3 TO SHOW UP
TONIGHT.
>> HE WAS AMAZING IN THE THIRD
QUARTER.
16 POINTS, ALL OF HIS THREE
POINTERS.
YOU ARE RIGHT, HE IS ON A
MISSION.
AS YOU KNOW, FAN DUEL IS RUNNING
OUR FAVORITE BET, THE THREE BY
TWO FOR EVERY GAME IN THE NBA
FINALS.
TONIGHT WE ARE MIXING IT UP.
WE ARE OFFERING YOU A CHANCE TO
BET THE THREE BY TWO PARLAY.
SIMPLE.
WILL THERE BE TWO THREE POINTERS
MADE IN THE FIRST THREE MINUTES
IN THE FIRST HALF?
WILL THERE BE TWO THREE POINTERS
MADE IN THE FIRST THREE MINUTES
OF THE SECOND HALF?
THERE WERE 27 MADE IN THE FIRST
IN GAME ONE.
WE KNOW THE TEAMS ARE VOLUME
SHOOTERS.
HERE IS A LOOK AT THE ODDS BOOST
FOR THE THREE BY TWO PARLAY
OFFERED BY OUR FRIENDS AT FAN
DUEL.
PLUS 420.
G MONEY, WHAT DO PEOPLE NEED TO
TAKE HOME A PAIR OF SNEAKERS
AFTER TONIGHT'S GAME TWO OF SUNS
AND BUCKS?
>> TRY TO TAKE AWAY SOME
SNEAKERS, I NEED YOU TO GET IN
THE COMMENTS AND TELL ME IF THE
THREE BY TWO PARLAY WILL HIT
TONIGHT.
TELL ME WHICH PLAYERS ARE
DROPPING THE BALL.
ACTUALLY HITTING THE THREES IN
ORDER TO WIN THIS $250 IN
SNEAKER MONEY.
ERIN, WHAT IS YOUR TAKE?
WHAT ARE YOU LEANING WITH?
ARE YOU LEANING WITH YES OR NO?
>> AS FOR THE LAST TWO SHOWS WE
HAVE DONE ON THE GROUP CHAT, I
ALWAYS SAY, YOU JUST HAVE TO
TAKE IT.
OF COURSE, NOW IT'S PARLAYED AT
PLUS 420.
YOU ARE OUT OF YOUR MIND IF YOU
THINK I'M NOT GOING TO SAY TAKE
IT.
THE BUCKS SHOT 44% FROM THREE IN
GAME ONE.
MUCH BETTER THAN THE SUNS, GOING
11 FOR 34 BEHIND THE ARC.
AT PLUS 420, I FEEL LIKE IT'S
SOMETHING YOU HAVE TO TAKE.
>> ERIN, WHEN YOU HIT YOUR BETS
AND YOU LOOK AT YOUR PHONE AND
THEY COME THROUGH, IS IT LIKE A
TIGER WOODS FIST PUMP?
DO YOU YELL OUT LOUD?
DO YOU JUST TAKE IT IN QUIETLY
AND SAVOR THAT MOMENT?
>> I FEEL LIKE I JUMP UP, BUT
I'M NOT DOING THE TIGER WOODS
THING.
THAT'S A BIT MUCH.
YOU HAVE TO HIT A 12 PARLAY TO
BE DOING THAT.
>> EVIDENTLY, G MONEY HAS HIT
SOME OF THOSE.
HE HAS SLIDES.
>> TELL ME WHAT YOU ARE BETTING.
>> NO DOUBT, RIGHT?
MILWAUKEE HAS BEEN DREADFUL FROM
SHOOTING DOWNTOWN IN THE EASTERN
CONFERENCE FINALS.
UNTIL GAME SEVEN.
THEY HIT 17 THREE POINTERS
AGAINST ATLANTA IN THE FINAL
GAME.
EXCUSE ME, GAME SIX, EXCUSE ME.
THEN IN GAME ONE AGAINST
PHOENIX, THEY HIT 16 THREE
POINTERS.
MILWAUKEE IS TRENDING IN THE
RIGHT DIRECTION.
I BELIEVE THEY'RE GOING TO
CONTINUE IN GAME TWO.
I'M LOOKING AT YOU BROOKE AND
DREW AND CHRIS TO GET IT STARTED
IN THE FIRST HALF.
OF COURSE, ADJUSTMENTS MADE AT
HALFTIME.
IN THE SECOND HALF, DREW, CHRIS
NEED THOSE BUCKETS.
I'M LOOKING AT MILWAUKEE BECAUSE
THEY ARE A TOP FIVE THREE-POINT
SHOOTING TEAM.
THEY WERE IN THE REGULAR SEASON.
FELLAS, JUST GET SOME SHOTS.
JUST GIVE ME TWO.
JUST GIVE ME TWO IN THE FIRST
HALF AND THE SECOND HALF.
WE GOOD.
G MONEY, WHO IS ROCKING WITH OUR
THREE BY TWO PARLAY IN THE
COMMENTS?
>> I AM IN THE COMMENTS.
I AM THE KING OF SPORTS.
IT'S GOING TO BE CROWDER.
HE HAS TO BOUNCE BACK FROM LAST
GAME.
OF COURSE, DREW HOLIDAY WILL
HIT.
TAKE IT TO THE BANK, THREE BY
TWO IS THE BEST BET.
I NEED THOSE KICKS, G MONEY.
SHOUT
SHOUTOUT TO YOU.
YOU ARE WALKING AWAY WITH THE
HOODIE.
RIDING WITH THE THREE BY TWO.
I HAVE ELLIOTT SAYS, I THINK
BOOKER WILL CATCH FIRE FROM
THREE IN THE SECOND.
BE QUIET IN THE FIRST.
ROCKING WITH BOOKER CATCHING
FIRE.
I DON'T THINK HE IS BETTING THE
THREE BY TWO.
KEEP ON MOVING ON.
I SEE NOT ZACH LEVINE.
BOOKER WILL HIT THE FIRST ONE.
CHRIS MIDDLETON WILL HIT THE
SECOND OFF A HIGH BALL SCREEN.
THANK YOU FOR GOING INTO DETAIL.
ONE MORE.
ZACHARY --
>> WAS THAT WORTHY OF A HOODIE
OR SNEAKERS?
I FEEL LIKE YOU ARE ON THE VERGE
OF GIVING AWAY A PAIR OF
SNEAKERS.
>> YEAH, YEAH, YEAH, YEAH.
I'M ON THE VERGE OF GETTING --
I'M ON VERGE OF GIVING AWAY OF
SNEAKERS.
BUT THAT WAS NOT IT.
I'M ACTUALLY LOOKING FOR WHO I'M
GIVING THE SNEAKERS TO.
I SEE ONE MORE.
ONE MORE, HUFFLE PUFF.
BOOKER WITH THE THREE BY TWO
ALONE.
BOOKER IS GOING TO HIT BOTH
SHOTS TO MAKE THIS THREE BY TWO.
I THINK THAT'S WORTHY OF THE
SHOES.
I WAS GOING TO GO ONE MORE.
THAT'S WORTHY OF THE SHOES.
>> WAS IT HUCKLE -- WHAT WAS THE
NAME?
>> HUFFLE PUFF 22.
>> ARE YOU RIDING WITH HUFFLE
PUFF 22?
ARE YOU GOING ROGUE?
>> IS THE SKY BLUE?
OF COURSE I'M RIDING WITH YOU
AND ERIN AND EVERYBODY IN THE
AUDIENCE THAT'S RIDING WITH THE
THREE.
THIS IS THE BET THAT WE CREATED.
RIGHT HERE.
WE CREATED THIS.
THIS IS A SUNSET BET.
THIS IS THE BET THAT'S BASED OFF
OF VIBES.
OF COURSE, I'M RIDING WITH THE
THREE BY TWO.
WE GOTTA HIT TODAY.
LET'S GO.
>> SALUTE TO HUFFLE PUT OR
SCUTTLEBUTT.
I'M SORRY I'M DISRESPECTING YOUR
PERSONA
USER GAME.
I'M SHURE IT'S PERSONAL.
ENJOY THE SUNSET VIBES AND YOUR
NEW KICKS.
IT FEELS LIKE, SPEAKING OF
SUNSETS, IT FEELS LIKE THERE'S
DIVINE INTERVENTION HELPING THE
PHOENIX SUNS IN THESE NBA
PLAYOFFS.
THEY PLAYED THE LAKERS WITHOUT
ANTHONY DAVIS.
THEY PLAYED THE NUGGETS WITHOUT
MURRAY.
THEY PLAYED THE CLIPPERS WITHOUT
LEONARD.
NOW THEY PLAY THE BUCKS.
THERE ARE A FEW CONTENDERS FOR
FINALS MVP.
WHO IS WINNING THE MVP?
HERE IS THE CALL.
CHRIS PAUL IS THE LEADER.
HE HAS 47% OF THE VOTE TO WIN
FINALS MVP.
DEVIN BOOKER, BROKEN NOSE AND
ALL IS 28 1/2% OF THE VOTE.
DO YOU FEEL THE SAME WAY AS THE
AUDIENCE IN THIS PARTICULAR
VOTE?
CP3 IS YOUR GUY TO WIN FINALS
MVP.
>> LET ME TAP IN WITH THE
AUDIENCE FIRST.
THEN I WILL TELL YOU HOW I FEEL
ABOUT THIS.
WHAT I NEED EVERYBODY IN THE
AUDIENCE TO DO IS GET IN THE
COMMENTS AND TELL ME WHO IS
WINNING FINALS MVP AND ALSO TELL
ME WHY.
THE COMMENTS ARE WITH THE BEST
TAKE, THE BEST TAKE IS EARNING
THEMSELVES $250 TOWARDS WHATEVER
KICKS THEY WANT.
ERIN, GIVE US YOUR TAKE.
WHO DO YOU THINK IS WINNING THE
MOST VALUABLE PLAYER.
>> THE AUDIENCE THINKS HE CAN
WIN.
I SPOKE TO THE DIRECTOR OF
TRADING YESTERDAY.
I ASKED HIM IF CP3'S NUMBER IS
AN OVERREACTION TO HIS GAME ONE
PERFORMANCE.
HE SAID FROM THEIR PERSPECTIVE
CHRIS PAUL 155 WAS PROBABLY TOO
SHORT OF A NUMBER AHEAD OF GAME
ONE.
THIS WAS DUE TO THE NARRATIVE OF
CP3 FINALLY, POTENTIALLY BEING
ABLE TO WIN A RING.
WE EXPECT IT TO MOVE OUT IN
FAVOR OF CHRIS PAUL.
I CAN'T TAKE CP3 MINUS 150 RIGHT
NOW BASED ON THE VALUE.
I DO THINK THAT HE IS GOING TO
WIN MOST VALUABLE PLAYER.
I THINK I'M GOING TO BET ON THIS
WHEN THE LINE POTENTIALLY MOVES
DOWN.
>> ARE YOU GOING TO WAIT UNTIL
MILWAUKEE WINS OR MAYBE
MILWAUKEE IS UP 2-1?
DO YOU NEED PLUS MONEY IN THIS
SITUATION, ERIN?
>> I DON'T NEED PLUS MONEY.
I JUST THINK MINUS 150 IS HIGH.
MAYBE LET'S SAY, FOR EXAMPLE,
THE BUCKS WIN TONIGHT, THAT LINE
WILL COME BACK DOWN TO PROBABLY
MINUS 110.
THEN YOU TAKE THAT.
>> OKAY.
YOU MENTIONED NARRATIVES.
THERE ARE TWO COMPELLING
HOLLYWOOD ENDINGS AT PLAY.
CHRIS PAUL WINNING A
CHAMPIONSHIP AFTER 16 YEARS IN
THE NBA.
EARLY EXIT, UNTIMELY INJURY,
BLOWN LEADS.
HE INJURED HIS SHOULDER THIS
YEAR AGAINST THE LAKERS.
I HURT HIS HAND AGAINST THE
CLIPPERS.
HE IS PLAYING AT HIS HALL OF
FAME CALIBER IN THE MOST
IMPORTANT GAMES OF HIS
PROFESSIONAL CAREER.
THEN THERE'S A KID WHO GREW UP
IN POVERTY, SELLING TRINKETS ON
THE STREETS OF ATHENS, GREEK,
WHO OVERCAME CULTURAL, LANGUAGE,
INTERNATIONAL BARRIERS TO BECOME
AN MVP AND POTENTIALLY A
CHAMPION.
HE ALMOST BLEW OUT HIS KNEE TEN
DAYS AGO, TWO WEEKS AGO.
THOSE ARE THE COMPELLING
NARRATIVES THAT ARE AT PLAY WITH
CHRIS PAUL.
I LOVE NARRATIVES.
IN THIS CASE, GIVE ME THE
UNDERDOG.
GIVE ME THE GREEK GOD AT PLUS
500.
THERE'S A LOT OF VALUE ON THAT.
I THINK PERSONALLY THAT THE
BUCKS ARE GOING TO TURN IT
AROUND.
THIS IS GOING TO BE A LONG
SERIES.
BUCKS IN SIX -- I WOULD LOVE TO
SEE BUCKS IN SEVEN.
I'M LEANING CLOSER TO BUCKS IN
SEVEN.
WHERE DO YOU FALL?
ERIN IS LOCKING IN CHRIS PAUL AT
SOME POINT DURING THE SERIES.
I GOT THE GREEK GOD.
WHERE ARE YOU LEANING FOR FINALS
MVP?
>> LET ME TAP IN WITH THE PEOPLE
BEFORE I GIVE MY PICK.
I WANT TO SEE WHERE THEY ARE
LEANING.
I GOT JOE GOING WITH YANNIS.
>> LET'S GET IT.
>> WHO IS ON A MISSION TO GET
HIS RING, CP3?
WHO BALLED OUT GAME ONE, CP3?
SHALL I GO OUT?
YOU ARE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE.
DA FOR FINALS.
YOUNGEST BIG TO GRAB 2020 AND
FINALS AND HE WILL DO IT TWICE.
MISSED 20 BOARDS BY ONE IN GAME
ONE.
HE WILL WIN MVP AVERAGING 22,
16, 2 AND 2.
SHOUTOUT TO WEE SMITH 44.
I LOVE THAT TAKE.
LOVE THAT TAKE.
WEE SMITH 44, I AM GIVING YOU
$250 TO BUY WHATEVER KICKS YOU
WANT.
BECAUSE OF THAT TAKE WAS SO
FIRED.
THAT TAKE WAS FIRE.
LOVE THE TAKE.
I'M GOING TO GIVE AWAY ONE MORE
HOODIE.
I GOT DRUBY 69.
CLIP ALL FOR THE SWEET STATE,
MAYBE HIS BROTHER.
HE IS GOING WITH CHRIS PAUL.
THAT'S SUPER FUNNY.
THIS ONE IS INTERESTING.
THIS ONE IS INTERESTING, VERY
INTERESTING.
WHENEVER I SEE YANNIS AT PLUS
500, I HAVE TO TAKE A STEP BACK
AND GATHER MYSELF.
THAT IS VERY ENTICING.
VERY, VERY ENTICING.
MY GUT TELLS ME, THE SUNS ARE
GOING TO WIN.
YANNIS ISN'T GOING TO WIN MVP.
I THINK THERE'S A MAN ON A
MISSION NAMED CP3 WHO WILL BE
THE MVP IF THE SUNS WIN THE
CHAMPIONSHIP.
I'M GOING TO ROCK WITH CP3.
I'M GOING TO LISTEN TO ERIN.
I'M GOING TO LISTEN TO HER.
SHE SAID, IF THEY LOSE TONIGHT,
THE VALUE IS GOING TO GO UP.
YOU KNOW WHAT I MEAN?
LOOK AROUND, SEARCH, GET VALUE.
I DO THINK IF THE SUNS WIN THE
CHAMPIONSHIP, CP3 WILL BE MVP.
>> THE SUNS ARE LEADING 1-0.
GAME TWO IS TONIGHT.
IN THE FIRST GAME, THE PHOENIX
BIG THREE COMBINED FOR 82
POINTS.
A REALLY IMPRESSIVE DEBUT FOR
CHRIS PAUL, BOOKER AND IT WAS
A -- DEANDREI WAS OTHER WORLDLY.
SHO
SHOUTOUT TO SUNS IN FOUR WHO WAS
BANG ON IN HIS PREDICTION
AGAINST THE NUGGETS.
HERE WE ARE IN THE FINALS.
THESE ARE THE ODDS FOR THE
CORRECT SCORE.
WE ARE ABOUT TO MAKE
PREDICTIONS.
G MONEY, WHAT IS YOUR BOLD
PREDICTION YOU ARE MAKING TODAY
IN THE NBA FINALS AS YOU SEE THE
PRICES AND MENU THERE AS FOR
WHEN WILL THE SERIES END.
>> BEFORE I JUMP IN, I GOTTA
TALK TO THE PEOPLE FIRST.
GOTTA GET THEIR INPUT.
YOU KNOW I'M A MAN OF THE
PEOPLE.
I'M A MAN OF THE PEOPLE.
I HAVE TO GET THEIR INPUT.
WHAT I NEED YOU IN THE COMMENTS,
EVERYBODY THAT'S WATCHING, WHAT
I NEED YOU TO DO IS GET IN THE
COMMENTS AND TELL ME WHICH TEAM
IS WINNING THE SERIES AND HOW
MANY GAMES ARE THEY WINNING,
WHAT'S THE SERIES.
IS IT 4-1?
IS IT GOING TO BE 4-2?
IS IT GOING TO GO SEVEN, FIVE?
EXPLAIN TO ME IN THE COMMENTS.
TELL ME WHY.
GOTTA SHOW THE WORK.
YOU HAVE TO PUT THE EFFORT.
WE WANT HOT TAKES HERE.
WE WANT HOT TAKES ONLY.
ERIN, WHAT IS YOUR PREDICTION.
WHICH WAY ARE YOU LEANING?
>> I HAVE SUNS IN SIX.
I SEE THE SERIES GOING THE
DISTANCE.
REMEMBER, THE BUCKS WERE DOWN
TWO GAMES TO THE BROOKLYN NETS
ONE OF THE FAVORITES TO WIN.
BUCKS ENDED UP WINNING IN GAME
SEVEN.
YOU KNOW THE BUCKS HAVE THE
CAPABILITY TO COME BACK EVEN IF
THEY ARE DOWN.
WE SAW YANNIS PLAY 35 MINUTES.
HE LOOKED MUCH BETTER THAN I
ANTICIPATED IN GAME ONE.
GIVE ME SUNS IN SIX.
GOOD VALUE AT PLUS 440.
>> YOU THINK PHOENIX WILL WIN?
THEY WILL WIN ON THE ROAD?
PHOENIX WINNING ON THE ROAD,
THAT WOULD BE DEVASTATING FOR
THE MILWAUKEE BUCKS.
>> IT WOULD.
>> I'M LOUD AND THAT -- I DON'T
KNOW WHAT THEY ARE CALLING IT.
IT'S LIKE -- IT'S THE MILWAUKEE
VERSION OF JER ASSIC PARK WHERE
THERE ARE THOUSANDS OF FANS
OUTSIDE OF THE STADIUM WATCHING.
I CAN'T REMEMBER WHAT IT'S
CALLED.
IT'S THE -- I'M USUALLY -- I'M
OFTEN LOUD WRONG ABOUT MY
PREDICTIONS ON THE GROUP CHAT.
I REMEMBER YOU SAID THE BROOKLYN
NETS.
I WAS WRONG ABOUT A KD
PERFORMANCE.
IT WAS LIKE KD OVER/UNDER 30.
HE DROPPED A 50 PIECE.
YOU AND G MONEY WERE CORRECT.
YOU KNOW HE WILL GO OFF BECAUSE
HE IS THE BEST SCORER.
I'M QUIETLY GOING TO ROOT FOR
THE MILWAUKEE BUCKS IN SEVEN.
I'M USUALLY LOUD WRONG.
SINCE THESE PLAYOFFS HAVE BEEN
SO UNPREDICTABLE, WITH INJURIES
AND UPSETS.
WE MIGHT ACTUALLY SEE A SUNS IN
FOUR.
I'M SAYING -- I'M ROOTING FOR
MILWAUKEE IN SEVEN.
THEY ARE GOING TO WIN ON THE
ROAD AND DEVASTATE THE PHOENIX
FAN BASE.
THEN THAT NIGHT, YANNIS, BROOKE,
DREW, THEY WILL GO OUT IN SC
S
SCOTTSDALE AND ORDER THE BIGGEST
BOTTLE OF DOM P.
THEY ARE GOING TO HAVE THE BEST
NIGHT OF THEIR LIVES.
IT'S GOING TO BE A LONG SERIES.
GIVE ME BUCKS IN SEVEN AT PLUS
550.
G MONEY, WILL YOU MAKE THE SAME
BOLD PREDICTION, BUCKS IN SEVEN?
>> NO.
ABSOLUTELY NOT.
>> COME ON, MAN.
>> ABSOLUTELY NOT.
I'M GOING TO GO OPPOSITE OF YOU
HERE.
I DO THINK IT'S GOING SEVEN.
I DO AGREE WITH YOU ON THAT.
I DO SEE CHRIS PAUL BOO, BOOKER
AND THE BOYS FROM ARIZONA TAKING
THIS ONE IN ARIZONA.
THE GAME SEVEN WILL BE IN
ARIZONA.
I SEE THIS ONE GOING TO PHOENIX
IN SEVEN.
I'M IN THE COMMENTS.
I NEED TAKES.
I'M LOOKING FOR TAKES.
I GOT DROW305, SUNS IN SIX.
THEY ARE ON A MISSION.
WE HEARD THAT HERE TODAY.
SHOUTOUT TO YOU.
YOU ARE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE.
HOT TAKE BUCKS IN SEVEN.
THEY DIDN'T BEAT THE SUPER TEAM
OF ALL TEAMS, THE NETS, FOR
NOTHING.
YANNIS ISN'T GOING DOWN EASY.
HE IS ROCKING WITH YOU.
SHOUTOUT TO YOU.
YOU ARE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE.
POET DADY SAYS SUNS IN FOUR.
>> THAT IS BOLD.
>> SHOUTOUT TO POET, YOU ARE
WALKING AWAY WITH A HOODIE.
I THINK ABOUT IT.
>> I DON'T THINK WE HAVE SEEN A
SWEEP IN THE FINALS SINCE I WANT
TO SAY TONY PARKER AND THE SPURS
IN 2007.
I COULD BE WRONG.
I THINK THAT'S THE LAST TIME WE
SAW A SWEEP AGAINST A YOUNG
LeBRON, 22 OR 23 LeBRON.
>> THE LAST TIME WE SAW A SWEEP?
>> I'M SORRY.
>> COME ON.
COME ON, MAN.
>> IT WAS AGAINST CLEVELAND.
>> IF YOU DON'T KNOW, GOLDEN
STATE WARRIORS WAS THE LAST TEAM
TO SWEEP.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT -- SHOUTOUT TO
THE SPURS.
BUT YEAH.
>> I DON'T KNOW IF IT COUNTS IN
THE RECORD BOOKS.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR TAPPING
INTO THE GROUP CHAT.
THE NBA FINALS EDITION OF THE
GROUP CHAT PRESENTED BY FAN
DUEL.
REMEMBER WHAT YOU LEARNED TODAY.
CHRIS PAUL IS THE FAVORITE TO
WIN FINALS MVP.
MAYBE TAKE A COUPLE OF GAMES
OFF.
MAYBE WAIT UNTIL AFTER MILWAUKEE
WINS A GAME OR TWO AND THEN LOCK
IT IN TO GET MORE VALUE AS PER
ERIN.
GET ON THE THREE BY TWO PARLAY
FOR THE FIRST HALF AND SECOND
HALF.
GET ON FAN DUEL.
RIDE WITH THE GROUP CHAT.
IF YOU DIDN'T GET ANY KICKS
TODAY FROM GREG DURING THE SHOW,
WE ARE GIVING AWAY THREE MORE
PAIRS AFTER THE GAME TONIGHT.
GET ON INSTAGRAM.
GET INTO THE SPORTS BETTING
STREAM ON THE APP.
WE WILL DM YOU IF YOU WIN.
WE WILL BE BACK FOR GAME FOUR
WEDNESDAY.
WE WILL GIVE AWAY ANOTHER SIX
PAIRS OF KICKS.
THAT'S $1,500 IN FREE SWAG.
IF YOU WON, YOU WILL GET A DM
FROM US.
THANK YOU FOR TAPPING IN.
WE ARE LEAVING THE GROUP CHAT.
E
ENJOY GAME TWO, EVERYBODY.
PEACE.